hey guys welcome to my official vlogging
floor first off I wanted to apologize
because I don't think I'm going to be
able to give videos up today yesterday I
had a little bit of a rough day
nothing too earth-shattering nothing
major not really that big of a deal in
all honesty but to something that kind
of kept me low throughout the day so I
wasn't gonna record yesterday because I
wasn't feeling up to the task
so I was going to record this morning
that usually involves getting up at 5
a.m. warming up for an hour while
getting down to the office recording
editing and uploading all for the 8 a.m.
deadline and I've done that more times
than I'd like to admit but just this
morning when I got up I was hoping I was
going to feel better but I'm still
feeling like you know I could uh I could
I could do with a little bit of a break
and I know everyone would look to take a
lot break but really it's not work that
getting to me it's just you know I just
had things going on that once again I'll
be super vague about and probably make
people worry more than they should it's
really ok I'm going to be totally fine
but I think that for today I'm actually
going to take a little bit of a break in
the meantime though it has been a long
time since I mentioned the videos that I
was in on other people's channels and
there's been a lot since the last time I
mentioned it and it's been like months
since I actually mentioned legitimately
the videos that I bet I recently out put
the videos up here a tabletop with Queen
Wheaton Brea grant al sharpton Ali
brought I didn't even have to go up and
look that up I got up and halfway up
absolutely it's not how sharp and Sally
brush I was with them playing the game
legendary and it was a lot of fun really
funny episode I thought it was
thoroughly entertaining I a great
strategy but it didn't work and also
check out the blue brief for that right
over there it's really funny too like I
thoroughly enjoyed the experience and
being on a set like that with those cool
people was really really rewarding so if
you haven't seen that already please
check it out also I was
on song biscuits with rhettandlink where
we were making me five nights at
Freddy's song you can check that out
right here you probably have already
that I think that video has quite a few
views on it so hopefully you guys have
found that but if you haven't if you've
are seen that you may not have heard the
podcast that I was on with them there
will be a link for that down in the
description below it's about an hour
long but we talk about a lot of really
interesting topics also I think I
mentioned that I was on game grumps on
Grum Kade for Mario Kart with Ross but I
do not think I mentioned that I was on
grump Kade again with Aaron for a brutal
Mario World which is right there it's
about ten episodes a whole series long
that you can check out it's really was a
lot of fun it was great it was tough as
hell and really hard to get through but
it was a lot of fun and hopefully we'll
be doing more episodes of that in the
near future there's also a ton of other
stuff that I've been in that I may have
forgotten right now I'll put look check
the description all the links will be in
the description so you'll find all of
this stuff down there and I'm I'm pretty
sure that's it so hopefully there's
something that you haven't seen yet that
you get some entertainment out of today
check out some other like cool channels
you know all the people that I've worked
with they're great guys and they do a
lot of cool stuff and oh I don't even
mention think I mentioned when when we
did the whisper challenge we did another
challenge on Matthias's channel called
the sound effects challenge and that was
a really cool video I don't I I know I
put a link to it at the end of the
whisper challenge but I don't know if it
was very obvious that it was a new video
so check out that there's also the other
alternate ending for the Taylor Swift
thing that we did so links once again in
the description down below so you know
sorry again that I'm not feeling up to
the task
you know usually I'm always happy to be
there for entertaining you guys and I
always want to be but you know
I am I am human I guess I haven't
checked recently but I'm pretty sure I'm
still human so I'm just gonna take a
break in
I'll take enough I think I'm going to
relax and play video games all day today
because I haven't had the opportunity to
play video games for myself in a long
time
bad timing air conditioner I'm almost
done shut up for a little bit longer so
I'm just going to take a breather and I
might go down to a store and buy Arkham
Knight because I haven't seen I haven't
had a chance to play that or actually I
might finish up Dragon Age Inquisition
because I still haven't beaten it yet
it's just you know it's hard to get
started on new games nowadays because I
used to in the past sit down and hunker
down for 12 hours at a time and just
play play play and you know that's not
exactly healthy but it was it was a good
stress reliever and I just haven't had
the time to do that
so you know I'm gonna I'm gonna take a
breather today so once again I'm very
sorry about you know not gonna be able
to make the news today I'm pretty sure
I'll be back in swing things tomorrow
like I said it's not nothing
earth-shattering nothing end of the
world that's happened to me I'm not
going back to the hospital and nothing
bad has happened so just I had a little
bit of a little bit of a low day and
I'll be over it in no time so either way
thank you guys so much for watching I'll
put up the videos to click here again so
click any of those annotations all of
them are good you can check out all of
them if you want I really hope you enjoy
your Saturday
I hope you guys don't worry about me
because I'm fine I will be fine I just
need a little bit of a little bit of a
break it's not work that stressed me out
it's not making videos that stresses me
out it's not that it's just you know
something happened I'll be fine in no
time
so either way thank you guys so much for
watching check out any of the
annotations right there for more cool
videos and the links in the description
for even more stuff and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye